[Music]
in prison fight new you crying
I got boogers submitted by the abused
blue wall I know that it's not about you
know what we call the boogers and tigers
nose we call them boogies we have so
many bunnies have little boogies in
there oh did I see the suction thing no
yeah
flick that [ __ ] out no I don't like
Vietnamese people they just put their
mouths of the nose and stuff yeah it's
balut yeah oh shoot that my friend's mom
did that when he was a baby yeah crazy
and they get it and they swallow it I
spit it out she's Chinese
yeah me too do it I think I think it
yeah seven inmates were killed during an
overnight riot at a maximum security
prison holy [ __ ]
I read about this oh it makes me wonder
like cuz I know that it's a it's one of
those it really overcrowded prisons like
1,500 prisoners or some [ __ ] inmates or
whatever but can't well I don't
understand how the guards like I
understand the guards don't want to die
in rush in there but don't they have
like gas canisters and [ __ ] and like
just shoot pellets and she should just
shoot estrogen in there yeah oh I could
just cry and eat one they're just gonna
all complain like crazy I'm sure I'd
rather bad and dying
yeah well I think that'd be too
emotional it's all just be like complain
and just be really indecisive like you
do all a basin of a science no estrogen
into a dog into a dog that's what can't
even feel planes have you seen The
Longest Yard when they gave one of the
players yeah the best gin everyone's
trying real hard out here okay big
football guy yeah
just kumbaya with each other and then
they'd be a little catty but they just
with their words they'd be like your
hair looks dumb no I really didn't like
when you shake me last night
so yeah beat to death would be a
terrible way to die well a lot of these
guys died from stab wounds this [ __ ] was
like like we're gonna do this [ __ ]
riot and then cause all the [ __ ] and
then take out all these guys out at once
I heard it went on for a while tear gas
and [ __ ] where did this go down in South
Carolina so this happened at Lee
Correctional Institute where they has a
lot of the is it a for-profit prison I
don't know you know they all for-profit
are they yeah there's no nonprofit oh
yeah you know how would they call that
like maximum security is there like a
minimum security prison yeah there are
yeah like this one you can walk through
the front door we only have same access
like sniper towers and [ __ ] oh there's
ones we're like you can play golf and
stuff like it's like basically you're
Stewart and something like that it's
more of like a resort II looking at
anything how is she gonna get her street
cred then you stab some older whisk tiny
little like I wanna see a club bed so
what a good bed yeah that's what it's
calling a club bed like Club Med but
yeah it's like TVs yeah I want to see
you like those Arabs like the Martha
Stewart prisons I want to see those like
where do the billionaires go when they
commit a crime it just looks like you
got locked in a resort yeah this isn't
that kind of like Goodfellas you know
they're able to be together cuz they got
big got murder for racketeering so
they're able to cut like onions with the
little razor blade and I think they were
still in maximum or like like like
Pelican Bay or those kind of places but
then their area was like cooked up Oh is
he in orange
new black is a maximum-security
prompting so they weren't like filing
because they got sent to max like if
they got in trouble they would get sent
it down the hill to max yeah yeah so
this incident happened it began in a
housing unit around 7:15 p.m. and at
about 8:15 p.m.
that's when fights broke out in two more
dorms and then not until 3:00 a.m. was a
prison security yeah that's when they
got tired I wanted to go to sleep so
you're too many people I am bleeding to
death
yeah so I'm about to show you guys a
video cuz even a lot of didn't die like
they're still hurt bloodied there were
22 people that were transported to
outside hospitals 13 of them were
treated and released back nine of them
or six of them remain hospitalized and
seven died so I was there and that [ __ ]
went down I would just be like oh just
watch everyone else kill each other I'm
dead already
or I would just cut myself in the arm to
side bleed a little bit and then just
pretend and then they'd take me some
awesome guilt other people's blood and
what are they been trampled to the
corner where my bunk and then like when
I go to the hospital I can ask for ice
cream
[ __ ] is just stay in your room alright
here's the video glad you don't have
cameras that's right they have their own
legs yes the one that they smell
building all these counters smelly
Dookie mm-hmm here we go
Dookie footage
what is he doing [ __ ] he's like a blood
snail that's I wanna see you there buddy
wanna see a dead body
who's the Logan part was like a Logan
Paul of jail I'm surprised he wasn't
even there why is that on YouTube he's
at a 7 the other one was on snapchat
oh we guys like snapchat yeah a lot of
these guys have stuff on so that's
actually what this fight was about it
was about cell phones and what else
money
turf and cell phones that's what these
their cell phones and turf and mine so
this was during a time where all the
doors are opening they're all hanging
out it's not when everyone's locked up
in their own dorm or whatever yeah but
like I said I want to know how the [ __ ]
do they not get controlled is faster
sorry how do they not cuz I've seen them
break prison fights that's you yeah cuz
I've seen them break prison fights a lot
faster than us you know what they're
reporting but there were just four
officers on duty for the 250 to 260
inmates in the dorm that was before the
three hours it was too late only for
authors so even if they shock answers
they can't just go in and just yeah yeah
force is not enough yeah why would they
I have only four maybe everyone else had
family vacation the same time save money
yeah so they're in this Correctional
Institute it which houses the state's
most violent criminals criminals four
guards [ __ ] yeah for the most violent
shortage of 20% which means a lot of
these officers are working overtime to
fill in the gap oh and there's just they
have a crazy amount of shortage in deep
freeze guards but a lot of the stuff
though they could control from outside
like with the computer so they're like
okay go on your thing and everyone go
and saw the doors closed [ __ ] like that
happens yeah so unless they're all Van
Damme
yeah those are for Van Dam's baby pod
kick some ass but because of this
incident they shut down 15 prisons that
how was about 20,000 inmates for like it
was remained on lockdown fifteen prisons
around it yeah cuz they don't know what
is going on
yeah they might be sending messages she
like this like makes me realize for sure
like I cannot live that kind of life I'm
not cut out for that [ __ ] man I can't do
it like I want to get makeup done I
can't [ __ ] if it's too cloudy out of my
oh it's slightly hot in my sheets and I
can't think I might like it I get angry
I can't do that [ __ ] but it was a turf
war money I'm [ __ ] all that gangs like
yep like you can have jail turf I mean
bathroom to the basketball court that's
my you do that I know that orange is the
new black they have like it's by race by
race I know oh yeah I guess okay that
makes sense certain areas oh yeah that's
true the bleachers are the Mexicans or
whatever we didn't ever trade hey next
month I'll trade the Tennis Club for the
basketball court alright cuz I want to
play tennis this weekend you've been
having the handball for lay the last ten
years how about you train and I have a
20 year sentence no like I want to train
with you after I play tennis
oh that's right cuz I remember watching
gangland and then they were showing like
the Asians it was like six of them but
they had this [ __ ] picnic table and
they were guarding that [ __ ]
like it's gold and then every day they
would show like them working out and
just staying tough and then they're
saying how like they had everyone had to
like protect their area so yeah okay I
do remember now yeah yeah that's a rough
life every day you have to walk on your
chest or anything I would like I mean it
would be nice to just be like okay I'm
just gonna be someone's [ __ ]
protect politics everyone's after your
booty hole yeah be careful okay if you
if you want to [ __ ] my booty well fine
whatever you don't stab me I'm fine I
feel I feel like that would feel the
same for me booty hole yeah because like
that's that hurts to just relax it
you're fine you get used to it really
that's some great advice just relax just
relax let it go in that's not easy
manner sad I know and then there's this
one story about the youngest victim that
died he was 18 years old he was serving
a life sentence for murder or something
and his sister was being interviewed and
she was just saying like you know his
body was there laying there for two
hours like no one deserves that no
matter what happened but he murdered
somebody that's what he went into prison
but he got killed
yeah so then don't you also give up your
rights when you go in I'm not gonna say
it cuz like if you know I should say no
one deserves this well technically
you're not even considered a human being
or a citizen once you go in or something
well you still considered human because
I mean right yeah there's a lot of like
you know no cruel and unusual
punishments in Geneva Convention or
whatever yeah but I think we're also are
they saying like people could have
survived if they were giving medical
attention but they bled to death because
a lot of these people were just laying
there yeah I mean it makes sense that
they're laying there for hours because I
mean they were fighting for [ __ ]
hours eight hours eight [ __ ] hours
they only have four guards on staff like
it's just all kinds of [ __ ] up I mean
like when you go in there right like
let's say you have to join a game or an
organization to be protected and then
they send you out cuz it's like okay
it's war time where you know fighting
over cellphones and [ __ ] picnic
tables and then you got to go out yeah
and if they catch you like acting like a
[ __ ] not fighting or pretending then
you get punished
so here's no way
Oh fight yeah it's crazy I talked to my
friend that was in maths he's like dude
like you have to find someone you can't
just hang out on your own and you're
sitting there working out you just have
to look pissed off the whole time you
gotta join me at the gym anyway it is
exhausting I told him like how did you
he's like I was tired all-time like you
can't really sleep and everything you
have to plan everybody wait PTSD from
that yeah that's a lot of them end up
committing crimes when they get out so
we could go back in cuz they're just
users so you said that war annoys ya oh
no
[Music]